I broke my hand on the serve the world's
end afterwards I went to see Morag the
certain urse and she gave me two very
powerful painkillers which I took both
of and then she called me and said just
take one it was a fun night
spaced yeah that was my first kind of
lead role in a sitcom Tim was a kind of
extension of who I was at the time a bit
of a sort of sci-fi geek comic book fan
I wrote the series with Jessica Hines
who played Daisy who is an incredibly
gifted actress and writer together we
sort of came up with this flatshare
sitcom and got all our friends to be in
it and it was the first time the second
time actually we worked with Edgar
Wright where I really formed my creative
partnership with Edgar the first time I
played Tim bisley I was required to kill
a whole bunch of zombies and we shot the
zombie sequence one morning I was a
little bit hungover I seem to remember
the idea was that Tim had done so much
speed that he was hallucinating that he
was actually in the video game he was
playing which is Resident Evil 2
you want a piece of me come get some
and it was after that morning of
shooting that we decided we would quite
like to make a zombie film and that
zombie film was Shaun of the Dead Shaun
of the Dead short of the Dead was our
first feature film mine and Edgar and I
played the part of Shaun smileyriley as
his name was you probably didn't know
that is that was his dj name he was a an
electrical store retailed chap who was
stuck in a sort of cycle of torpor and
inactivity with his best friend ed much
to his girlfriends sort of disapproval
that really at the time was fairly
autobiographical Nick and I Nick Frost
and I who play dead were ensconced in a
pub in Highgate called the Shepherd's
where we spent much of our time to the
disappointment of our den girlfriend
Edgar Wright who used to try and get us
to go into town and go to the Groucho
Club and places like that where
celebrities hang out but we didn't want
to do that we wanted to stay in the pub
and my girlfriend at the time Maureen
who is now my beautiful wife for 13
years she also was trying to get us to
leave and we didn't want it so we wrote
a whole film about it and added zombies
when we came up with the idea for Shaun
we wanted him to stay in the same
costume for the whole movie apart from
the sort of thirst scene in the last
scene so we came up with this very very
distinctive white shirt red tie which
became his look and now every Halloween
I get sent pictures of people who dress
in that costume because it's actually
quite an easy Halloween costume to
replicate it's just a white shirt with
short sleeves and a red tie covered in
blood and your Shaun of the Dead Hot
Fuzz in Hot Fuzz I played the part of
Nicholas angel who was a very dedicated
police officer very by-the-book not a
maverick he was the opposite of the
classic action movie hero and he did
everything straight down the line and
during the process of the film he learns
to essentially dumb down and become more
like an action hero for Nicholas angel I
had to kind of do a deal bit more
research Shaun was basically me but
Nicholas angel was very very much not me
I had to go and do some research with
the police and hang out with cops you
know research procedure and all that
kind of stuff
if you drive a driver Long's and we put
the blues and twos on a couple of times
and went screaming around
and turn them off and then we're told
not to tell anyone that we did that now
we were lucky enough to be in the car
one time when there was a domestic in
the West Country and not it wasn't lucky
that the domestic happened obviously but
there was a big argument in some house
and lot of noise we got there with the
blue lights flashing and were careening
down some some alleyways in the West
Country which was an enormous fun and
fortunately nobody was hurt it was just
a dispute over a tractor
ever since I've had a nodding
relationship with most British police
officers you know usually the Bobby is
seen as a sort of slightly parochial
character when in actual fact you know
we thought it was time the British Bobby
got a call representative most of the
police that I encounter if not all seem
to be slightly grateful for that because
we weren't really taking the piss we
were actually kind of making a sort of
tribute pic so I've been let off so many
murders because of hot fuzz the World's
End Gary [ __ ] King is my favorite
character I've ever played Gary is a
lost soul a warrior in the name of
something completely pointless he was a
complex character and that Gary comes
across as being very annoying at first
and irritating and not someone you
particularly like because he seems
selfish at the expense of his friends
but you learn as the film goes on that
there's a lot more to him than that and
he's actually you know beset by
complications when the truth of him is
revealed you kind of slightly understand
with more clarity why he behaves the way
he does Mission Impossible 3 ghost
Protocol rogue nation and fallout Benji
Dunn Benjamin Disraeli done this know
his name I just made up I've got a call
once from this guy JJ Abrams I don't
happen to him but he called me at my
office and I was writing Hot Fuzz at the
time and literally said hey do you want
to come and be in Mission Impossible 3
and I said all right then why not I'll
give it a go he had a big future that
guy I'm just looking at anything and you
got something you're gonna go somewhere
I know where he went
it's weird I think I saw him in LA last
time I was there I was shooting in Skid
Row and there was a box with JJ written
on it and I left
to the lid and there he was skulking in
the background of this little box he was
just wearing a pair of white Underpants
and they were very grubby and I said
Jake ask me Simon remember from Mission
Impossible 3 but he was gone he was too
far he gave at least the game of the
opportunity to play Benjy for the first
time and subsequently three more times
in Ghost Protocol rogue nation and
fallout Benji was a sort of lab
technician who I think got a taste for
adventure in Mission Impossible 3 he
ends up being Ethan's GPS when he's in
Shanghai and I think that the thrill of
that the thrill of sort of being a bit
naughty and going rogue with Ethan gave
him a taste for adventure and so he
enrolled in the field agent program and
then when Ethan gets out of Russian
prison in ghost Protocol there's Benji
in the field and that's like seeing that
kid from ITV fixed your computer
yesterday suddenly with you in the mine
or whatever you're doing for a living I
don't know why being a mine so it's been
really fun playing Benji because he sort
of changed over the years he's become
more and more adept to more and more
capable but at the same time he's still
that wide-eyed wet-behind-the-ears kind
of new guy and for that reason he's sort
of the audience's way into these crazy
adventures Star Trek star trek into
darkness
Star Trek beyond chief engineer
Montgomery Scott Scotty is such an
iconic character and that's not anything
to do with me that's to do with James
Doohan who brought the character to the
screen in the first place and made him
such a beloved sort of feature within
the Star Trek TV series and latterly the
movies I was very lucky enough to be
offered the role of Scotty by the guy JJ
again I was able to take part in Star
Trek and eventually got to write
co-write a Star Trek film with a guy
called doc junk it was it became my dear
friend in the trenches of writing a Star
Trek film in six months is what we had
to do and it was it was no fun I love
playing Scotty a lot of people say my
accents terrible I'd like to say it's
not it's actually okay but people like
to be passive-aggressive towards
strangers because their lives are so
empty so you know how about it hang on a
minute
I've got to find my crewmates you help
me and I help you
all right well things being as they are
today I'll get a better offer today so
lead the way my wife is Scottish as such
shows half my family so they all help me
out with my accent and teach me words to
say like scanner and yeah we clatter
bastard and things like that so that's
really good fun having some authenticity
despite what mainly English people will
say oh you're Scottish actions rubbish
but most of the Scottish people I
encounter like hey well done lad you did
well so I love them for that I love the
Scots more than the English ice age dawn
of the dinosaurs and collision course I
play the catch of buck the weasel who is
a one-eyed weasel which is also often a
euphemism for a man's parts it's not a
euphemism for my part because my part
was actually buck the weasel who was
trapped in a prehistoric ice cave for
many years with a group of dinosaurs in
ice age dawn of the dinosaurs and then
came topside for Ice Age collision
course to help the Ice Age gang
Manny Diego that law avoid a collision
with a massive asteroid
I love Claire buck he's a he's a crazy
sort of ball of energy
you'd be surprised to know how
exhausting it is to play him even though
I'm only in a room with a microphone all
the time I've never met Ray Romano or
Queen or any of those guys I met Dennis
Leary once when I was younger but he
won't remember that and yet we've had
all these adventures together and that's
the strange thing about doing voiceovers
is that you sometimes or generally
always do it solo one day I'll get to
meet those guys and we'll reminisce
about the great times we had together
but until then they're not gonna happen
for in Paul I play the character of
Graham Willy who is the friend and
wingman of Clive Collings played by Nick
Frost my longtime friend and
collaborator Graham and Clive are two
nerds in the real sense of the word not
in the new sense where everyone's a nerd
just because they go and watch Ironman
and Clive and Graham are both big sci-fi
fans Clive's an author Graham was in
Illustrator they go to comic-con and
then they take a little pilgrimage out
to the black mailbox at area 51 in
Nevada when they get there they happen
to run into an alien on the run and they
help him get back to the ship it's like
a wish fulfilled for nerds really Paul
was played by Seth Rogen
an entirely CG character beautifully
brought to life by double negative I
become a father in Paul and you can look
out for this if you like I'm the same
when we knock on Terra's door and she
opens the door in the interim between us
knocking and her opening I went back to
Los Angeles and was present for the
birth of my daughter and then went back
to film the rest of the scene so when I
watched the movie I see myself become a
father in a single edit and it's ER it's
a remarkable little moment for me when I
watch that film which I do every week
because I love it so much Star Wars The
Force awakens Star Wars The Force
awakens is a film in a series of movies
which began in 1977 with Star Wars a new
hope as it was called a lot year after
it came out and then Empire Strikes Back
Return of the Jedi the Phantom something
attack of the things revenge
of something and then there was another
one and it's this and in that I play
unkar plutt who is essentially like a
scrap metal merchant and alcohol was an
interesting role for me because it was
fully synthetic suit fat suit silicone
mask with CG augmented features it was a
tough call because I was in the deserts
of Abu Dhabi in 50 degree heat and then
in Pinewood Studios in similar heat
because we were in a studio but it was
great it was great to play such an
important part in the Star Wars universe
and I hope I'm not spoiling it for
anyone to say that unkar plot in the
episode 9 will become something of a
significant character and he is actually
the force and as such means more I think
than any other Star Wars character
particularly hands Olo or Judah bakudan
or Luke Skywalker I love any chance I
get to work with Steven Spielberg he is
a fantastic director and a wonderful man
and it's someone who shaped my love of
cinema and films generally so yeah to
get to play up tomorrow was a tree Ogden
Morrow was the co-creator of the Oasis
with James Halliday who's played by Matt
Rylands I got to play Ogden at various
stages in his life as a young man as a
middle-aged man as an old man as well
and that was really good fun because I
got to go into have aging makeup and
that took about five hours but it was
really fun to look in the mirror and see
myself as an old man which I'd do every
day
but as an even older man let's say and
also do my old man walk which is to put
my hand just here and then walk a little
bit like this I like to watch old men
walking it's one of my favorite pastimes
often I'll get a nice position in the
park put a rub down get some sandwiches
and just watch old men walking around
it's quite easy to do because a lot of
them are partially sighted so sometimes
I'll pursue them for up to 2 or 3 miles
if they can make it that far and video
than walking and I have a large library
of old men walking around which I watch
in the evenings as I'm having my dinner
for me it's always about the money and
how much they're gonna pay me to be in
these films no I you know I mean you
look for complexities in characters you
look for layers and interesting sort of
subtext I love a character who has
something going on inside which you have
to communicate in subtle ways